this is one of iraq's people smugglers
he calls himself
is a fake name and he won't let us meet
near his home or film his face
he's
he's on his phone to contacts across the
smuggling network arranging documents
and travel for people wanting to escape
iraq for europe
he uses a cheap burner phone that can't
be traced regularly switching between
hundreds of sim cards and he tells us
they sometimes work with border
officials
will you occasionally pay them bribes
can you pay pay people bribes in order
to let
foreign
that has made him a rich man
last year he tells us he made a hundred
thousand dollars
he isn't ashamed of what he does and he
is prepared to risk other people's lives
for money including the migrants trying
to get to britain
[Music]
um
the mahmood family paid smugglers thirty
thousand dollars to get them to europe
in september they traveled via turkey
and entered belarus
sleeping rough some of the way
she got down and kissed the ground when
she crossed into poland
days later though they were caught and
put straight back on a plane to iraq
they are now living in a tiny rented
flat
because the smuggling gangs took
everything they had
and listen to how they eventually
crossed into europe another account of
corrupt officials helping the smugglers
they get a scissor of breaking fans
and they broke the fence and like go to
poland
belarusian police yes
the batteries police yeah
yes
you were part of a game do you think
between belarus and europe yeah like a
bull
characters
on summer yeah on the summer yeah
because we don't have life in here and
we don't have future and we don't have
money we don't have we lost everything
okay
no
she's crying
and every time
and she can't sleep
there are thousands of people like this
who will pay whatever it costs and risk
whatever it takes to start a new life in
europe
and encouraging them from the shadows of
the smugglers who take their money and
don't care less what happens to them
aleister bunker sky news iraq